I can't do this by a diamond micellar
water do can we please stop calling
protest tubes just because they're in
the same category even if they have
really similar ingredients they might
not have the same effect on skin but
these ones they have really different
formulas they're not even trying to be
dupes the bioderma relies on this
non-ionic surfactant to clean the
Garnier uses this hydrating solvent and
this amphoteric surfactant not juice
there is like nothing in common here I
could Naturally Fit this whole list on
these are both gel moisturizers so they
both have water humectants and a bunch
of silicones but everything else is
different